this movie unleashed it's a fascinating
idea for a movie we're gonna talk about
in a little bit but it involves pets and
I was just curious it's it's a woman
who's got this you know serious intense
connection with her pets do you have
pets are you a pet person I am a dog
person I love dogs um but I have a dog I
just I just adopted a dog but who hasn't
like yeah that's kind of boring I guess
yeah great but um I also have a 24 year
old frog do you really yeah I didn't
realize that frogs live that they live
that long you have a 20 you really do
have a 24 year old frog yeah but when
you're a kid and you order a frog in the
mail you don't think it's going to live
to be 24 right you order it in the mail
yeah
yeah what happened tell us how you even
though you could order a frog in the
mail yeah well I was really into frogs
when I was seven yeah and and I love
Dennis the Menace and he had a frog as a
pet and so I was like I want to get a
frog and and Santa brought me a grow a
frog I don't know if you guys know what
a grow a frog kit is but basically you
get a certificate you mail for a frog
and then you get a tadpole in a
Styrofoam cup in the mail yeah Wow
okay how'd that go well not well because
the first time around it was it was
winter in New Jersey and it showed up in
the mailbox and it was like a popsicle
it was a frozen it didn't think of that
at the fact that they should be thinking
of these things they just put it in a
typo and a little start from cup and
send it in the winter yeah and I cried
so hard I was a little kid I was so
upset right and and the purpose is like
you know you get to see a tadpole turn
into a frog you know and you get to see
their hands but it was just a bad pad
just saw a temple turn into one of your
dad's drinks so and then my mom said
okay let's wait until the spring it'll
be fine and so we ordered one in the
spring and it just happened to be like a
really really hot day in New Jersey and
the mailman put it in the middle mailbox
and it boiled oh my god yeah this is a
these are murderers with people winning
this
their tadpole murderers you know the
great thing about the girl frog company
of Massapequa New York honestly it makes
a great gift and they're still they're
still doing it um I'm not gonna promote
grow frogs yeah works eleven percent of
the time they have like a three little
bears like the first times do polled but
the third time just right and so I got I
got the third time was just right and I
got a little frog and named him Sam and
it was great and then he died but the
great thing is you just tell the girl
frog company that your frog has died and
you get a new one in the mail and so I
just kept doing that and then twenty
four years ago was the last time I did
it and this frog lives in my parents
basement in Pennsylvania it's still
alive yeah his name is dusty I had a
crush on this kid named Dustin and I
didn't want anyone to know so I was like
I'll just name him dusty and then well
now everybody knows I had a crush on
Dustin Jones hmm you were talking about
Dustin Diamond yeah we have a picture
you brought a picture of him there is
after all these years well he looks and
sometimes when my dad answers the phone
he'll go frog keeper speaking
[Laughter]
you